Okay. Good afternoon, everybody.
Welcome to the 2026 AACR meeting. I hope
everyone has enjoyed the first
day or day and a half, I guess it started yesterday.
I'm excited for today's session. This is a methods
workshop on cancer
metabolism, and we have three speakers in the session.
The way we're going to run the session is each speaker will give their talk, and
then we'll do, depending on how long the speaker talks,
roughly five to 10 minutes worth of questions for each speaker.
And the goal is to end on time at around, like what is
it? 2:30, around 4:00. So, let's get right to it.
Our first speaker is Josh Rabinowitz, who's going to talk about spatial
metabolomics of pancreas and breast cancer. Josh.
Thanks, Matt, and nice to see all of you.
The tumor is a battlefield between the forces of good,
our anti-tumor immune system, sometimes scarce good,
and evil, the cancer cells and supporting cells.
And key to the battle are the supply lines,
metabolism. And we have amazing technologies for
measuring metabolism at the whole tumor level, from imaging
technologies like FDG-PET, to
ex vivo technologies like metabolomics that can look
deeply at every metabolite in the tumor specimen.
The challenge is that those technologies don't tell us what's
available to the different cell types within the tumor, and that's what
I'm going to talk to you about today.
In particular, I'm going to talk about three questions.
So how do metabolite levels differ across different cell types in the tumor?
How is energy made? What substrates are providing energy in different
cell types in the tumor? And how can what we learn
from those two types of analyses be integrated with our
knowledge to think about ways of attacking tumors in the clinic?
And I'm going to talk about two technologies.
The first technology is the one that's in the title, spatial metabolomics,
based on MALDI imaging mass spectrometry.
What is this? Alright.
MALDI imaging starts with a frozen section, flash frozen
tumor tissue, cut into an approximately
10-micron thick slice, just as you would do for histology, but fresh tissue.
Then it's coated with an organic matrix that
absorbs UV laser light, and so this is the M and A in
MALDI, matrix assisted. So when that matrix
absorbs the UV laser light, the L for laser in MALDI,
then the matrix gets very hot, almost explodes off of
the surface, carrying with it gas phase metabolite and lipid ions.
That's the D and the I, the desorption
ionization process, that allows us to get, for every
5 or 10 micron sized spot on the tissue section,
a mass spectrum reflecting the metabolites and lipids present at that
particular location.
This is a image made with our latest MALDI
technology by the guru, technically, in this technique in my
lab, Lei Somara, who's on the job market right now.
And this is looking at the intestine at effectively single cell
resolution. The blue is a fatty acid that's enriched in the
epithelial cells of the intestinal lining.
You see the finger-like projections.
There's a single cell layer of epithelial cells.
And then in red, you're seeing false color code for the
extent of uptake of fructose that was
given in isotope labeled form. So it's heavy fructose, so we can track
exactly where it's going
and see where it is taken in and phosphorylated to make fructose
1-phosphate. And you see that fructose is being processed
preferentially in the bottom of the intestinal
villi towards the crypts, where
colorectal cancer tends to occur.
And fructose is one of the nutrients that when we take it in the diet, is
most strongly associated with risk of colorectal cancer.
So what's happening actually in tumors?
I'm going to start with breast cancer.
In particular, I'm going to start with hormone receptor positive, HER2 new
negative breast cancer, and that's all the breast cancer type I'll talk about in
this talk. You see here a clinical team that's made this
possible, as well as the postdoc in my lab, Meera Gupta, who's done all
of the tumor work.
And so breast cancer has a relatively straightforward
histology. You see the ducts that are the breast
cancer cells, some fibrosis, and here there's effectively no
force for good, okay? There's almost no immune cells detectable.
Then on the right-hand side here, you
see a MALDI image of two lipids.
And the remarkable thing is that these lipids encode exactly the
fibroblast versus the epithelial component of the tumor.
What's different in these lipids?
Well, they're both phosphatidylethanolamine lipids, that's the PE.
What they differ in is in the fatty acid tails attached to
this PE. The one in red that marks epithelium, and this
epithelial derived breast cancer, has two
18:1 tails, 18:1 meaning 18 carbons with one
double bond. That's oleate or the olive oil
characteristic fatty acid.
And then the fibroblast marking lipid
has more carbons total, one saturated tail, and then one
unsaturated tail, that's omega-6, effectively a seed oil type
fatty acid tail. And so what we learn from this image, first of all,
is that there are very specific lipids that, for
reasons we don't understand yetSelectively mark
different cell types within the tumor.
A key ongoing goal is to figure out what's the biochemical basis for
this lipid specialization, and is this actually driving
cell fate in the body?
Before we answer those questions, we can still use these lipids effectively as
markers to tell us what cell type we're looking at when we then go on and look at
metabolites. And I'm going to talk today about very classical metabolites like
glucose,
in the textbook, the beginning of making energy, ATP, the end
of metabolic making energy, the high-energy molecule that you may be aiming
for.
And so if we look in breast cancer, what I think you can see quite clearly,
again, these are all false color images where the brightness of the color
indicates the strength of the metabolite signal, is that
glucose is depleted where the cancer cells are within breast
tumors, and ATP is increased. And we see this
across all patients and all segments of tumors that we look at.
On the bottom is an overlay. When you see red and green separate, that
shows that the cancer cell marker is spatially distinct from the glucose.
Glucose is depleted in cancer. When you see yellow, that's
overlap. So the ATP is enriched in the cancer cells compared to
the fibroblast.
So we have glucose depletion. That makes sense. Cancer cells love glucose.
Warburg taught us that 100 years ago.
And the first thing they do when they take in glucose is make glucose phosphate,
and it's effectively a trapped version of glucose phosphate that allows
FDG-PET imaging. So we said, can we see glucose phosphate also
in these images?
And from a purely technical perspective, kind of is the
answer. So we get a beautiful-looking image at the mass of glucose
phosphate that's beautifully in the cancer cell, exactly what we wanted to see.
But after a great deal of work, we realized that there is an artifact going
on here. And the artifact is that we can get
an ion at the mass of glucose phosphate multiple
ways. The way we want to get it is because there's actually glucose phosphate in
the tumor. But when you hit laser energy into these tumor
slices, you can break things apart.
And one thing you can break apart is phospholipids, and if you break off the head
group of phosphatidylinositols, you can get glucose phosphate.
When you do that, you also get a similar metabolite that's lacking
water that you do not get from glycolysis. You see these two images are the same.
When those two images are the same, you know you're looking at an artifact, a lipid
fragment, not the actual glycolytic intermediate.
So that's a little technology warning for you all.
Okay. Let's go on now to pancreas cancer.
Pancreas cancer is histologically much more complex.
In this case, we have a more sparse battlefield.
The cancer cells are relatively rare, as you see in these little
red islands within the tumor. Lots of fibrosis, and there are immune
cells, but often immunosuppressive immune cells and not exactly where you
want them, typically not surrounding the cancer cells.
We can go to the exact same lipid markers that we used to define the
epithelial breast cancer, and they perfectly light up the epithelial pancreas
cancer cells.
Same thing for the fibrosis in pancreas cancer, exact same lipid.
And now I'm going to introduce one more lipid.
This has an omega-3 tail, effectively a fish oil tail,
and that lights up pretty well
different classes of CD45 positive immune cells.
What's the message now in pancreas cancer?
We're looking at three cell types, fibrosis, immune cells, and
cancer cells.
And so if you look here in the glucose image, you'll see areas where there's
clearly glucose depletion, and those correspond both
to this lymphocyte-rich immune infiltrate,
effectively a tertiary lymphoid organ within the pancreas cancer.
It's depleted for glucose, as is the areas where you have
epithelial cancer, and those exact same areas are
rich in high-energy adenosine nucleotides.
In this case, I'm using ADP as a surrogate for ATP because ATP
fragments to ADP. ADP is much easier to detect in MALDI
than ATP. I'll show you a bit more evidence that these really are high-energy
charge regions as we go along.
And this just shows the overlay for the immune marker.
You see the immune marker in an area with low glucose
and high ADP.
So in general, what we see in these tumors is that almost every
metabolic feature that we see in cancer cells is mimicked in
immune cells. So we see very stark differences between
fibroblasts and either cancer cells or immune cells.
But as we've seen so often in the cancer metabolism world,
cancer cells and immune cells vary metabolically similar,
unfortunately. One striking difference, and this is sialic
acid. This is not really a free metabolite.
This is an unusual sugar that modifies
both proteins and lipids, and it's a sugar that effectively
acts as a 'don't eat me' signal, a turn immunosuppressive signal to
immune cells.
It's shown here in two different patient slices at two different magnifications
from pancreas cancer. And what I want you to notice is wherever you see this green
sialic acid signal, you see no immune cells.
Absolutely none in the region here where you see
lots of sialic acid. And then here there's actually an interesting case where
you see immune cells surrounding PDAC cells, perhaps even
killing these PDAC cells. But right adjacent, you see other PDAC
cells that are secreting sialic acid, and they're completely
unmolested by immune cells. And again, we see this reliably across
patients.
Overall, what we see is that glucose, and not just
glucose, other fuels like glutamine are low in the cancer
cells,
and that ADP is high, and there's a high ADP to AMP
ratio, again, saying these are actually high-energy charge regions.
Uric acid is low. Uric acid very reliably goes up when cells are under
energy stress. And this all says that the cancer cells are
fuel poor but energy adequate.And this shows this is
exactly true over both breast cancer and pancreas cancer.
Every trend that we see between fibroblasts and cancer cells within the
tumor microenvironment is effectively preserved.
So how do nutrient-poor cancer cells maintain adequate energy charge?
And part of this is because the cancer cells are masters at
getting nutrients out of the environment, as are the
activated immune cells. Part of it is that cancer cells are masters at
growing with relatively little energy utilization,
and they do this by eschewing energy-intensive functions of the
tissue of origin. And you see the paper there by Carolyn Bartman, you can read on
that topic. And finally, of course, they are consuming glucose, and that
is giving them some glycolytic ATP.
So we really wanted to go deeper into understanding the fuel sources in these
cell types, and for that, I'm going to switch to mouse
and really focus on the fuels that are feeding into the
TCA cycle, because when we've carefully analyzed where most ATP
is coming from, not just in the normal body, but also in tumors, in the
vast majority of contexts, it's through aerobic
metabolism driven by TCA turning.
And this is work of another postdoc, Christian Piece, and he's going to look at a
bunch of different 13C level substrates and how they feed into
different cell types within the tumor microenvironment.
And the challenge in doing this is if you just
grow your tumors, do your tracing, and sort the cells, then the
metabolites during the sorting process can leak out.
They can even trade from one cell type to another, and you don't have confidence in
what you're seeing. And so to address this, we're going to use
two amino acids that are in rapid exchange with the TCA cycle,
aspartate and glutamate, as our readouts for TCA labeling,
and we're going to use those amino acids trapped in protein, effectively using
protein as a vault to store our labeling information.
And this is a technique that I first learned about at a meeting from Matt Vander
Heiden, our chair here.
And so there was one tweak to make this technique work well, and that's we got to
get our information out of the vault also.
And there was a challenge in doing this because in hydrolyzing protein, you tend to
interconvert aspartate and asparagine and glutamate and glutamine.
And ultimately, we were able to solve this with the help of our Nobel Prize-winning
chemistry colleague, David MacMillan, by doing a deuterated
reductive step on the intact protein to clearly mark all the aspartate and
glutamate residues. Once we had that in place, we could run this technique,
and we could get the exact same answers from bulk tissues as we'd gotten from all
of our classic tracing experiments where we looked directly at something like
citrate or malate. Key to making this work is also
co-infusing a central amino acid, and
we use valine labeled as a position that never enters the TCA
cycle as a marker for the amount of protein synthesized in each cell
type so that we aren't measuring protein synthesis, we're just measuring the
feedstocks of the TCA cycle.
When we've done this at the bulk level, one of the most important
messages that we learned was that almost every cell type in the body
uses lactate as a major fuel. You can see this
at the top here. Every cell type in the body uses lactate to
fuel the TCA cycle about one-third.
And this is true also in tumors that we've looked at in mice, and it's
true in lung cancers that Ralph DeBerardinis has looked at
in people. And so there's effectively a cycle where glucose that we eat
is converted in glycolytic cells within the body, mainly working muscle
into lactate, then fuels all sorts of cells in the body that are not
have the permission to use glucose.
Now, within the tumor microenvironment, is this universal use of lactate as a
fuel actually the rule?
There have been many high-profile papers over the past few years saying that
immunosuppressive immune cells particularly love to
use lactate as fuel, and this is part of why high lactate in the tumor
microenvironment is a problem. And one of the most impactful of
these papers came from Greg Dougherty's lab, and you can see the
tracing data, this time done ex vivo, okay, comparing use
of lactate as a fuel in the FoxP3 positive
Treg cells compared to T effector cells.
And you see what looks like a big difference. But does this hold in vivo?
And what we find is absolutely not.
In our in vivo studies in MC38 cancer cells, at
least in this tumor type, we see lactate is a
universal fuel. Just like it's universal against all organs of the body, it's
universal across all cell types in the tumor with frankly
indistinguishable contributions between different tumor cell types,
including using this Treg reporter mouse so we can very cleanly
compare Tregs to effector T cells, and they have
identical lactate contributions.
Now, not everything contributes identically, and one of the most interesting
differences that we found is specific utilization of
3-hydroxybutyrate, also known as beta-hydroxybutyrate or a ketone
body,
by the CD8 positive T cells within the tumor.
And this aligns very nicely with data from many labs
showing that 3-hydroxybutyrate can be a powerful both fuel
and epigenetic modifier, a subtle donor for epigenetics
in effector T cells. An example of this from Rusty Jones
I think is particularly nice because of the genetic component.
He uses caloric restriction in order to get better
antitumor immunity that you see in the blue line, so
that mice live longer in a way that's dependent on their immune
system and that caloric restriction is inducing 3-hydroxybutyrate
via ketosis, and that extension in lifespan is lost
if you make the T cells in that mouse incapable
of using
3-hydroxybutyrate.So
within MC38 tumors,
I showed you that all cells use lactate.
We get similar results for glucose and glutamine.
Immune cells use acetate. I didn't show you that, but they use it much more than at
least MC38 tumor cells. And CD8 T cells,
particularly like 3-hydroxybutyrate.
And putting together then the two parts of the talk, you can
see that the cancer cells are glucose-starved, and
so it might be good to stress them more by making them even more glucose-starved.
The T cells are really liking 3-hydroxybutyrate.
And of course, a single diet can combine these two features of low
glucose and high 3-hydroxybutyrate, and that's a ketogenic diet.
And so we wanted to see, could this actually help in
pancreas cancer?
For those of you who are not familiar with ketogenic diet, it's a very high fat,
moderate protein, very low carbohydrate diet.
Kind of like what's on the screen, except more bacon and less asparagus and salmon.
Okay?
This diet lowers glucose a little bit in the bloodstream.
But what's very important here, I think, is that intramural glucose in pancreas
cancer is way lower than blood glucose.
And at least in mouse experiments, proportionally falls more in
ketogenic diet than does blood glucose, all the way to below one
millimolar, so you have genuine glucose restriction within
the tumor.
What happens when you combine this with other stressors like a targeted
therapy, like a PI3K inhibitor or classical
chemotherapy, in this case, gemcitabine,
abraxane, and
cisplatin.
So what we saw i-in experiments, this is Lou Cantley's
experiments that informed the field a great deal, is that the
combination of PI3K inhibitor and ketogenic
diet could profoundly slow pancreas cancer growth.
And similarly, some positive results combining it with chemotherapy in
our hands.
Over the intervening years, we've learned that there was a complication in these
experiments, and that's the one we were comparing standard mouse chow to
ketogenic diet. The mouse chow was loaded with all sorts of stuff
from plants, all sorts of plant phytochemicals, whereas the ketogenic diet
was clean. It was clean milk protein and oil.
And all these phytochemicals end up mattering.
And the way that they most obviously matter is they affect liver drug
metabolism. And so one reason why you were getting so much better
responses here in the ketogenic diet context was the
liver drug metabolism was slowed down by the lack of phytochemicals
in the ketogenic diet, and so that was one factor.
But perhaps fortuitously,
uh, we didn't learn about that fast enough, and so we went forward
to do a clinical trial. Uh, this is the work of Gail Jamieson, Dan
Von Hoff, and many other colleagues who worked incredibly
hard to pull this trial off. Looking at first-line
metastatic pancreas cancer, treating with state-of-the-art triple
chemotherapy, this was before RAS inhibitors, with or without
a supervised carbohydrate-restricted diet.
Patients made their own food, uh, but with supervision from a
company called Virta Health that was doing electronic monitoring of their ketosis.
The trial was never powered to give a definitive answer, right, but it had
16 valuable patients per arm randomized.
And it's trying to give us a clue, is this worth pursuing more?
And I think the upshot i-is very much so.
So on the left here, you see the progression-free survival data.
There's about a three-month benefit in terms of progression-free survival
in the ketogenic diet group. On the right, you see overall survival,
again, favoring the ketogenic diet group with a little bit more than
three-month benefit. Of course, we want to give more than three months to our
pancreas cancer patients. But if you look at the clinical benefits that were
achieved when gemcitabine was introduced, when abraxane was introduced,
these were about three-month clinical benefits.
RAS inhibitors, thankfully, are going to do more, but they're not going to do
so many fold more. So this is a meaningful benefit in the context of pancreas
cancer.
It's particularly meaningful given that this is a very tough diet.
A minority of the time were patients actually in ketosis.
When they were in ketosis, they were not in very deep ketosis, and there was a
correlation between the extent of ketosis and longer
survival in the trial.
So with that, I'm leaving you with the idea that tumors are glucose depleted,
especially around both immune cells and the cancer
cells, that the intramural T cells are avid 3HB
consumers, and that therefore, the combination of
lower glucose, higher 3HB, and ketogenic diet is something worthier of further
clinical exploration. I want to thank the very many people and
collaborators and funders who helped pull off this work.
Thank you for your attention, and I'll take any questions.
Okay, if you have questions, please,
I think... Yeah, come up and use the microphones up here through the front.
Um, while people are walking up, I'll ask a first question, Josh, and that is,
um,
do you see lactate or 3-hydroxybutyrate depletion in your
MALDI mass spec experiments? Or
are they too small to pull out?
Uh, they're too small to pull out right now.
We're working with Bruker, who built the instrument, on a new
instrument. Hopefully, it'll be installed in a couple of months, and we may get
answers on that, but we don't get usable images at that low
molecular weight right now.
Great. Sarah.
Here. Hi.
Hey.
Very, very nice. So I have a question about the very first part, the imaging.
Mm-hmm.
And I'm interested about the stromal part.
Because you were talking about CAFs, but I was wondering if you
can get the resolution really to distinguish between
regions where you have the fibroblast or region where there is only the matrix
or maybe also macrophages that can be tightly connected with the
CAFs.
Yeah. I think we're continuing to work on finer and finer
segmentation. I think this is a very important question, and,
yeah. So
wholeheartedly agree. I think hopefully more to follow as we
continue to refine the cell type identification.
Okay. Can you remind me the resolution that you reached?
The intrinsic resolution in these images is 10 micron spatial
resolution. From the laser spot perspective, we have no problem going to
five micron. As you might have been able to see in some of the images being
very faint and grainy-
Mm-hmm
... it's very hard actually, a lot of the measurements, especially metabolites as
opposed to lipids. And as you go to finer spatial resolution, you get more and
more noise and less signal. So we're constantly working on that front.
Okay. Okay, great. Thanks.
Great. We'll go one more on this side, and then we'll go.
So...
Hey. Victor Shu, Government Freedom.
I'm curious why you think you get such beautifully clear cancer lipid markers
in the absence of sort of alterations to these very basic pathways.
Yeah. I think that these are probably things
that are encoded in the normal physiology.
So we see those same markers marking fibroblasts versus
epithelium in many parts of the body.
And so we do think that there's a developmental
program that involves
lipid specialization. Whether that's a happenstance program or whether
that program plays a core role in driving cell identity, we don't know.
Of course, if it plays a big role in driving cell identity, then maybe there are
opportunities to attack it to address cancer.
Great. Now we'll go to this side.
Great talk. So Yue Fan from Johns Hopkins.
So I'm wondering whether this technology can be used to see
whether like a protein glycosylation changes or cell surface
protein changes by those labeling and could see the cell
interaction different during this process. Thank you.
Yeah. It's a great question. Of course, the whole glycosylation field is
so complicated. The sialic acid is a teeny drop
in that direction. That's what I'll say.
I think when you have a very clear specific subunit that's towards the end
of the glycosylation and can fragment, and sialic acid is negatively
charged, which helps gives a decent signal. All those things come together.
I think to me, at least it's a beautiful image.
But in generally decoding the whole glycan code this way, I think will be
very difficult.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah. Hi. Great talk. Alfredo Budion from Cancer Center in
Naples, Italy.
I end up to see meta-analysis, and
our lab work on metabolomics in serum.
And this meta-analysis show, and we produce some data
that in the peripheral blood, hydroxybutyrate
actually correlate with poor survival, more aggressive cancer and so on.
Can you comment these in the view that you presented?
Are there any ideas, for example, that, in
this case,
the patients and the cells cannot use or
uptake hydroxybutyrate, and then it accumulate or...
I don't know.
Okay. First of all, fascinating observation.
It's the first time I hear it, so I think it's great education for me.
One thing that would be on my mind with that is, are those
patients systemically under energy stress because their appetite is
suppressed, be it in some version a cachexia?
So we know that patients who are really sick end up with appetite suppression, and
that will drive them into ketosis.
So I wonder if this is not ketosis as the problem, but
ketosis as an indicator of a patient that's not taking in enough
food. But really interesting and obviously something we should dig into and discuss
more.
Okay. Last question.
Sunil Badwe, Emory. Two questions.
First is
follow-up of the previous question that you answered.
Do you see any differences into normal versus
pre-neoplastic versus neoplastic epithelium?
I don't know that we have the proper comparison to look at
that, but certainly impression is yes, that like core
metabolism is distinct in the tumor.
Okay. The second question is, once you feed the animals ketogenic versus
non-ketogenic diets, do you see any difference in the metabolic
profile in the tumors?
Yeah.
In the tumors.
Say that again.
Metabolic profile of the tumors.
Yeah. And so I don't have the imaging all done
for that. We're working on that. But at a bulk level, the tumors are massively
different. The body is massively different.
Use of 3-hydroxybutyrate as a fuel increases a great deal.
Use of glucose as a fuel is suppressed substantially.
So yes, there's a massive rewiring of both regular and tumor
metabolism in the ketogenic diet. Thank you.
Okay, great. Thanks so much.
Okay. Our next speaker,
whose slides will be coming up shortly, is Gerta Hoxha
from UT Southwestern, and she's going to tell us about
metabolic regulation of cancer cell growth. Gerta.
Thanks, Matt. First of all, I want to thank Matt for the kind invitation to be
here and present some of our lab work.
My lab is interested in decoding metabolism.
We're interested in the fundamentals of metabolism in the context of cancer
and metabolic disorders. And as we all know, metabolism is
vastly complicated, but at the same time, is highly regulated.
However, metabolic processes get deregulated in
response to stress, bad diet, genetic factors, and this can lead
to cancer and metabolic syndrome.And in the vast
realm of metabolism, my lab has been particularly interested in nucleotide
metabolism. Both the classical nucleotides, purine and
pyrimidines, which are part of the
genetic material, make RNA and DNA, but are also important
factors for energy generation. But we're also interested in other
classes of nucleotides, and in particular in nucleotide redox
cofactors, NADP and NADPH.
NADPH is a dinucleotide, which is a
general electron donor in the cell.
It's really important for anabolic metabolism, but
also generation of glutathione and thiredoxin to
support antioxidant system. And in today's talk, I'll
primarily focus on NADPH metabolism.
So NADPH gives the cells the power to reduce, and
one key characteristic
of this metabolism is its
compartmentalization. NADPH cofactors exist both in the
cytosol, but also in the mitochondria.
And primarily, we have studied these processes through the lens of two
metabolic kinases, which are called NAD kinases.
Mammalian cells encode two NAD kinases, cytosolic NADK,
which phosphorylates NAD to generate NADP, which is then reduced
on NADPH to support biosynthesis, but also inhibit ROS,
as well as mitochondrial NDK2, which provides
reducing power in the mitochondria.
We've been primarily interested in these metabolic kinases because of their
association with cancer, and they have emerged as
important cancer targets. So for example,
some previous work of mine has shown that cytosolic NADK
is regulated by oncogenic PI3 kinase signaling, but
also work from Blenis and Anagoma has shown that NAD
kinase is also subject to regulation by other kinase
signaling, such as KRAS. We've seen that these enzymes are upregulated
in cancer, and mutations in NAD kinase can drive
PDAC, but other
cancers.
More recently, about 10 years ago, another kinase was discovered, and this
was NDK2. Similar to NDK,
NDK2, if we look at cBioPortal data, it's also highly
amplified in various types of cancer, and in particular is
amplified in lung cancer. And we didn't know much about
NDK2 except for
its role in antioxidant generation, and it was thought that the
major function of mitochondrial NADPH is to
recycle
glutathione to inhibit ROS, given that mitochondria is a
major site of ROS. However, given
its association with cancer and of course, these are reducing
cofactors that they are important, we wanted to know more if there's
more functions of mitochondrial NADPH beyond
ROS.
So we knocked out NDK2 in a variety of different
proliferating cells and cancer cells, including lung cancer cells,
and it was very apparent that NDK2 loss has a strong
effect on cell growth and proliferation, shown here
with these black marks. And if we take cancer
cells and put them in tumors, as shown in here in this A549 lung
cancer tumors, we see that NDK2 loss has a strong and
drastic defect also on tumor growth.
Perhaps it's not very surprising that when you knock out a key metabolic
enzyme that you reduce cell fitness, but we're
very curious if there were certain metabolic dependencies of mitochondrial
NADPH. So we gave cells a variety of
metabolites, including antioxidants, nucleotides,
fatty acids,
and amino acids. And what we observed was that loss of
NDK2 was completely restored by giving
non-essential amino acids, and we have about seven of these non-essential
amino acids. And what was really striking was that in
particular, proline was really key for proliferating
NDK2 knockout cells. So proline alone was able to
restore cell proliferation in these proline
auxotroph NDK2 knockout cells.
So we asked the question, why proline?
So proline metabolism is
quite easy compared to any other metabolic pathways.
We can generate proline in the mitochondria through conversion from
glutamate into glutamine semialdehyde, which is then cyclized to
P5C, and it's reduced to proline. And as you might
appreciate in these cofactors here shown in violet,
NADPH is one of the cofactors that seems to be required for proline
metabolism. So we perform metabolic tracing, this case with
glutamine, to look at generation of newly synthesized proline.
And what was one of the most black and white results that we
have seen, at least in my lab, was that loss of NDK2
completely disrupted proline biosynthesis,
indicating that NDK2 is essential for proline
generation. And this gave us also a little bit of closure to explain
why these cells can't grow without proline, and the reason is that,
well, they cannot make proline.
So basically, I identified that a key role of mitochondrial
NADPH is to generate proline to sustain cell growth and
proliferation.
However, we were very curious beyond proline and beyond ROS, whether
mitochondrial NADPH could also have other functions in the
cells. So as many people in this audience and in
metabolism do, we went back and performed a steady-state metabolomics
experiment in isogenic cell lines.
And in addition to proline, we also observed that several
metabolites in the TCA cycle, including citrate,
isocitrate, fumarate, were also reduced in
NDK2 knockout cells.To us, this was a little
bit of a surprising result, and that's because we know that NADPH
supports many processes, especially anabolic processes and
antioxidant processes. However,
there's no connection between NADPH
and TCA cycle, as TCA cycles runs primarily on
NAD.
So we went deeper into why NADK2 and how NADK2 might
affect TCA cycle. So in this case, we performed pyruvate
tracing. So pyruvate is the end stage of
glycolysis, which enters the TCA cycle.
It's decarboxylated or oxidized by an enzyme called PDH
and generates acetyl-CoA, which then is conjugated to
oxaloacetate to generate citrate that jumpstart the TCA cycle.
So in an isogenic setting of NADK2 wild type and knockout
cells, either in the presence or absence of proline, as we know, because
proline is one of the major functions of mitochondrial NADPH,
we assess the TCA cycle, and interestingly, we observe that various
metabolites in the TCA cycle, where the fractional abundance of them were
reduced in NADK2 knockout cells. However, this was not dependent
on proline, indicating that mitochondrial NADPH
regulates TCA cycle independently of proline.
And given that the first metabolite citrate was reduced, we were
curious whether the step of the regulation might be upstream and
perhaps at the pyruvate dehydrogenase step.
So for this, we did a time course experiment with pyruvate tracing and looked at
acetyl-CoA production. And interestingly, we observed a reduction
in acetyl-CoA levels in every time point in response to NADK2
loss, indicating that we have an impairment in pyruvate
oxidation. We did many experiments, including in vitro
assays of PDH activity, as well as radioactive
assays when we would label with radioactive
pyruvate and measure the captured CO2 via
radioactivity. Again, another surrogate assay for PDH
activity. And again, we observe a reduction in
pyruvate oxidation, indicating that NADK2 loss
somehow affects the pyruvate dehydrogenase step.
But how does it affect? So what is PDH?
So PDH or pyruvate dehydrogenase is a really critical enzyme
in the mitochondria. It's a complex that
has three subunits, E1, E2, and E3, and it's important because it's the
link between glycolysis and TCA. So basically, it's the entry
point of pyruvate to generate energy in the TCA cycle.
It's a highly regulated enzyme. It's regulated by cofactor
availability. It's regulated by phosphorylation events.
But it's also regulated by more exotic post-translational
modification, and one of these post-translational modification is called
lipoylation. So lipoylation is the C8 group or
a lipid group that is attaching to the E2 subunit of PDH,
and basically, it acts as a prostate group and
facilitates substrate channeling.
And it's really critical for optimal enzyme activity.
So we looked at many functions and many regulatory modes of PDH,
and what was very surprising was that loss of
NADK2 had an effect on PDH
lipoylation. So here, this is an immunoblot of endogenous
DLAT or the E2 subunit. And as you might
appreciate, loss of NADK2 shows a reduction in lipoic
acid, and when we give back NADK2, we can restore
lipoic acid. So this is an antibody-based assay.
However, we've done also mass spectrometry to
define the sites that are lipoylated.
So protein lipoylation, as I mentioned, it's a rare
post-translational modification.
In fact, it's so rare that it only happens, or to date, it's only found in
five proteins, and these five proteins are all in the mitochondria
and are present in four complexes.
One of them is DLAT in the PDH complex.
OGDH complex also has DLST. Both of these
fuel the TCA cycle. But there's also lipoylated components
that are found in glycine cleavage system as well as
BCKDH in the breast chain
complex. So we were curious whether NADK2 affects general
protein lipoylation or whether there's something specific about PDH.
So in order to address this question, we expressed these various components
that are known to be lipoylated, either in wild type or NADK2 knockout
cells. And in general, we observed that there is a reduction
in lipoic
acid in all of these proteins, indicating that NADK2
loss affects general protein lipoylation.
Given that enzymes might
either act as scaffolding,
so we were curious whether
the activity of NADK2 was critical for this.
And in order to answer that question, so again, we used an isogenic
system of NADK2 knockout cells, where we either added
back active NADK2 or
kinase-inactive NADK2, or we
engineered cytosolic NADK with a mitochondrial targeting
sequence to edit in the mitochondria, and now we're restoring
mitochondrial NADPH. Interestingly, we
observed that whenever we have mitochondrial NADPH, either with
active NADK2 or with cytosolic NADK that
is in the mitochondria, we see that there is restoration of lipoic acid,
indicating that there's actually NADPH in the mitochondria, not just
NADK2, that matters for lipoylation.
So what impacts protein lipoylation by
NADK2? So when we read the literature, we found that a
key pathway that determines protein lipoylation is mitochondrial fatty
acid biosynthesis.
SoThis has remained an obscure pathway,
and I'm sure that a lot of you have heard about the cytosolic fatty acid
biosynthesis, which is a critical process for generation of fatty
acids, for energy generation, for membrane generation in the
cells. However, mitochondria has a specialized
fatty acid synthesis called mitochondrial fatty acid biosynthesis that
actually, it's not really linked for energy generation or for
membrane or cardiolipin, even though people thought that it could be important for
cardiolipin synthesis. But it's very tightly
coupled to the mitochondria function and to oxidative
metabolism.
However, this pathway has remained obscure, and what we know
about this pathway has been primarily coming from the work from
bacteria or genetics from yeast. And the reason
that we haven't quite measured this pathway in mammalian cells
is because of the chemistry. So fatty acids in the
mitochondria are elongated on top of
another protein called the acyl carrier protein.
So basically, you have the covalent modification of these fatty acids that
are further elongated on top of ACP.
So a general method like metabolomics or lipidomics would not
reveal this fatty acid that are attached to ACP.
However, work from bacteria has suggested that some of this enzyme, for example,
MeCCR, in this pathway, can use NADPH.
So we were, again, very curious whether mitochondrial NADPH can
supply mitochondrial fatty acid synthesis.
However, no one had measured this before in mammalian cells.
We were very inspired by work from Doug Allen at the
University of Missouri, who had measured mitochondrial fatty
acid in plants, and in particular in these
Camelina plants in oilseed crops.
So Doug had collected a lot of crop, and
their lab basically used an endopeptidase which would
release these
acyl chains from the acyl carrier protein.
So now we can detect the acyl chains
using
classical metabolomics techniques.
So, I wrote to Doug, and we started a collaboration with
him, and he was very, very generous and sent us all the standards
for ACP.
And we tried to see if we can get it to work in mammalian cells.
So first, to set the system, we use
MeCCR wild-type or knockouts. So MeCCR is one of the enzyme in the mitochondrial
fatty acid biosynthesis. And MeCCR loss,
as expected, reduces lipoic acid production.
We expressed acyl carrier protein with a FLAG-tag.
We purified it and used a similar endopeptidase,
Aspen, in order to release this acyl chains
from ACP. And this was a really cool result
that indeed, after a year of optimization,
we managed to see that in MeCCR knockout cells, so in these enzymes
that doesn't
have a functional mitochondrial fatty acid biosynthesis, we see a reduction in
almost all the various acyl chains from this
ACP from C2 to C12. Nevertheless, that wasn't
our primary question. Our question was whether mitochondrial
NADK2 was also important for
mitochondrial fatty acid biosynthesis.
So we performed similar experiments in
various cell lines. Here I'm showing you HeLa cells in wild type and
NADK2 knockout. And it was really nice to see that
indeed, NADK2 loss reduces mitochondrial fatty
acid biosynthesis and various chains in this pathway.
And while this work was primarily through biochemistry, it was
very gratifying to see other data sets, and in this case, the
depth map, where we looked at the correlation of NADK2 with
various genes. So we noted that three genes in mitochondrial
fatty acid biosynthesis correlate with NADK2, including MeCCR,
MCAD. Genes in the lipoylation pathways, such as LIP1
and LIP2, also correlate with NADK2.
We see genes in the TCA cycle and ETC.
But we also noted another class of proteins, and the large class
shown here in pink, of mitochondrial translation
that were also correlated to NADK2.
And we were very curious about this because in yeast,
at least, there was some indication
or observation that mitochondrial fatty acid synthesis had been linked
to mitochondrial translation.
And we wanted to test that. So in order to test whether NADK2
or mitochondrial fatty acid synthesis in mammalian cells impact mitochondrial
translation, we adopted a method from the EMBO
Report to measure mitochondrial translation.
So in this particular assay, we basically inhibit
cytosolic translation with an antibiotic called harringtonine, and then we
use click chemistry to
specifically measure mitochondrial translation.
And in these images in here, we're looking at mitochondrial translation in
pink. You might appreciate that loss of NADK2 and mitochondrial
NADPH shows a strong reduction in mitochondrial
translation. And
as mitochondrial translation supports ETC function, we also see that ETC
complexes are disrupted, and we see a strong reduction in
oxygen consumption rate by mitochondrial NADPH.
Thus,
we identified another new role of mitochondrial NADPH
and NADK2, and in this time, is to
support mitochondrial fatty acid synthesis to power oxidative
metabolism, to support lipoic acid, cellular
respiration, as well as mitochondrial translation,
thereby expanding the repertoire of the functions
of mitochondrial NADPH cofactors beyond ROD,
but also,
basically, we found that proline and MTFAS are two major roles.
Currently, we're working to understand how these
various roles of mitochondrial NADPH, roles
proline, and MTFAS play a role in lung cancer in germ
models, but we'll have
some data in maybe one or two years regarding that.
So with that, I want to thank my lab,
our collaborators, as well as our funding sources, and you for listening,
and I'm happy to take questions.
Okay, questions.
I'll wait for Gina.
It is a long walk.
If you yell, I can repeat it too.
My question is about NNT. And so when we looked at
NNT's role in mitochondrial metabolism, we saw
an impact on iron sulfur clusters, but not methylation.
I'm wondering if you looked at NNT, and if there's some
compartmentalization of mitochondrial NNT.
Can you explain it, or what are your thoughts on that?
Yeah. So the question is about NNT, and
when Gina knocked out NNT, they saw-
Yeah
... it affected iron sulfur clusters. And have you looked at that?
Hopefully, that's a fair summary.
Yeah.
Thank you for the question. We've looked at NNT.
Of course, if you remove NADK2, NNT can't function, so
NADK2 looks like it's dominant. We're actually working currently,
and that's a new story that is going to probably be ready in a
couple of months from my lab. But we do see an effect, a
new role of NADK2 in iron sulfur cluster and heme
biosynthesis as well,
which we think is related to redox and potentially...
Yeah.
Cool. Over here.
Great talk. I'm wondering if there's any clinical overlap
with the NADK2 amplification, whether like
subtypes of lung cancer or what Ralph has described with the
oxidative high. Do you see an enrichment for this small subgroup of
patients?
Yeah, that's a great question. So
there are about three subtypes of lung cancer that NADK2 is
amplified.
We all know that redox is really critical in lung cancer,
so adenocarcinoma is one of those.
In particular, we saw some association with NADK2 and P53.
So when P53 is down, there's a strong correlation with
NADK2 being up. So we're particularly looking at KRAS
P53 model and in
GEM model with minus plus NADK2. But, yeah,
we don't have any results yet. But yeah.
Thank you.
Hopefully the mic's fixed.
Very interesting talk. I was wondering since fat synthesis and
mitochondrial regulation may be related to immune
regulation, do you have any links or any data
linking the NADK2 to immune response?
Yes.
Great questions. Not published, but we have generated the mouse
model, and NADK2 loss has a profound effect
on immunity. Hopefully, we'll publish
that maybe in a year or so. But yeah, thank you for the insight and
question.
Beautiful talk. Kind of a follow-up on the last question.
Do you have any other safety insights into NADK2?
Sorry, Josh, could you repeat the question?
Do you know anything about the importance in the
general wellbeing of animals beyond the immune system effect you just mentioned of
NADK2? Like, does muscle still function?
Is their whole body knockout viable, that kind of thing?
Yeah. The primary role of
NADK2, this is unpublished, but it's bone marrow failure.
So that is the major role that drives most of the
phenotypes. So we went after a few different
organs, but the predominant one is the bone
marrow.
We see other phenotypes as well. We haven't looked particularly in the
muscle. It's one of the things that I was thinking that maybe it should be
important for
regeneration of the muscle. I would assume, in particular, I think
NADK2 is very tightly correlated to cell
proliferation. So I would say that we're going to also
look at the intestine, but there's a very strong connection with stem cells, cell
proliferation, and that's where we see the major roles.
Great. Thanks.
Thank you.
Fred.
Yes. Hi, Gerta. Very nice work. I have a question.
You mentioned that
NADK2 may be implicated in mitochondrial protein
translation. And do you have an idea if it is also
implicated in the maturation of mRNA and
tRNA in the mitochondria?
Yeah, great question. That is sort of
a
great question because we don't know exactly the mechanism of how
NADPH relates to mitochondrial translation.
We haven't quite looked at the mRNA, as you're asking.
We think that at least from the mitochondrial fatty acid
biosynthesis part, this acyl carrier protein is very interesting because
it's part of the complex one.
It has these various acyl chains that interact
strongly with
the mitochondrial ribosome system.
So we see at least wherever you have mutants
or defects in mitochondrial fatty acids or NADK2, we see less
association of this acyl carrier protein with all the mitochondrial
ribosome. Now, I don't know exactly what the ACP is
doing with mitochondrial ribosome, but definitely, we see less interaction.
So getting more insight into why these chains or the length
of these chains matter for that process, it's
a very interesting question and something that we're interested in.
But thank you for the question.
Thank you.
Wait. So Gerta, I had a very similar question, so I want to clarify something
there. So if you knock out
Like the MECR or one of the-
Correct
... clear enzymes required for mitochondrial fatty acid
synthesis. Do you also see the same translation defect?
Yes. We see a very strong translational defect with
MECR knockout as well. And if you look at DepMap data, similar
to NADK2, there's a big part of mitochondrial fatty
acid synthesis, it's associated with mitochondrial translation.
And we show that at least in mammalian cells, that was the case, but the
mechanism
of that, it still needs a little bit more work.
Okay. Great. All right, fantastic. Thank you.
All right.
So the last speaker in the session is me.
So I'm Matt Vander Heiden, and I'm going to talk to you about some work
that we've done on how metabolism influences cancer progression,
and given that this is a method section, I will try to highlight
some of the methodological things that
hopefully helped us do this. So here's my
disclosures. Okay.
All right, great. So,
we've heard from this session as well as the prior session earlier today that we
know metabolism is altered in cancer.
We know this is true in real patient because we have tests like this, FDG-PET
scan, that clearly show that there's differences in
metabolism between tumor and other tissues within the host.
And I think what we in my group have been particularly interested in
over the last several years is really our efforts to understand
various metabolic phenotypes in cancer, I think have been increasingly leading us
to say that, yes, these phenotypes help to adapt to
various
states, that is become a tumor, metastasized, et cetera.
But I think increasingly, what we're starting to realize is that maybe some of
these metabolic changes also are driving some
of the events that lead to cancer progression.
And that's one of the stories that I want to tell you about today.
And then the other one is actually going to harken back to some whole body
metabolism. Josh introduced this a bit, but I want to share with you a little work
we've been doing to try to understand some of the links between
pancreas cancer and
tissue wasting.
Okay. Now, if we just think about here's methods that are used in
the clinic to look at differences in metabolism in patients.
And I like to point out that most people are familiar with FDG-PET, but
this is not the only PET modality that exists in patients to looks
at metabolism. We have here Fluciclovine PET.
This is something to do with amino acid uptake.
FLT PET is basically a BRDU assay or
thymidine uptake. And I point these out not because I'm
going to spend a lot of time about various PET modalities, but to point out that I
think many people know that not all tumors are PET positive.
Well, not all tumors are Fluciclovine PET positive or FLT PET positive.
That is, each different cancer type seems to have its own
spectrum of what various PET tracers it takes up, which
I think at some deep level tells us something about the metabolism of the tumors.
I think it says that not all cancers do the same metabolism, and
that has led us as well as many other groups to want to ask the question, well, if
not all cancers do the same metabolism, what determines the
metabolism that individual cancers do?
And I'm going to summarize work here from many groups.
It really comes down to three factors.
Initially, the field of cancer metabolism, the resurgence and
interest in this field came from the observation that various genetic
mutations can affect metabolism, and that's absolutely true.
But I think increasingly what we've realized from work by
Josh, but also many others as well, that where cancer
comes from also can affect the various metabolic phenotypes of
cancer cells. And of course, where the
tissue or where the cancer is located, that is the nutrients in the environment,
seems to have a quite important effect on the metabolism
that cancers do. And at some level, I think this makes some sense because
these are sort of cell intrinsic things that have to do with the tumor.
That is, these define the network of what metabolism
can actually accomplish. But if you take any network and you put
it in a situation where nutrients are infinitely abundant,
well, that network is going to look very flexible.
And the reality is that real cancers arise in tissues where not
all nutrients are available. And so that has led at least
us, but many others as well, to really focus on this notion that
maybe it's the constraints placed by nutrients in the environment on the
cell-intrinsic networks that exist within individual cancer
cells that ultimately are creating these bottlenecks that determine what
different cancers can do, and ultimately may reflect why it is
that you see different metabolic phenotypes across different cancers, as well
as different dependencies across different cancers as well.
And so for the last several years, my group has been very interested in trying to
better understand what nutrients are actually in the environment, and this is
where some of the techniques that Josh introduced earlier can become very useful.
Things like mass spectrometry to measure nutrient levels.
And we and others in the field have now done this across many different
tumor types. And because a lot of this is published, I'm just going to show you one
experiment. This was done by Keene Abbott, a former graduate
student in the lab. It was published earlier this year.
But it's sort of illustrative what we and I think others in the field
have been finding is we've been asking, well, what nutrients are actually
found in various locations, in this case within a mouse, but it's also true
within patients. And I think this is just a principal component plot that is a
way to sort of collapse all of the quantitative mass spectrometry
data that we've collected onto a single 2D plot.
And effectively, what we all know that
what weGive cells in standard tissue culture is not
physiological.
But this actually points out, well, this is the nutrient environment of blood.
This is the nutrient environment of all the various tissue sites that Keane could
take out of a mouse. And what you can see here is that, well, blood is different
than tissue culture, not shown, but blood is also different from what's in
various tissues. And I think increasingly what I at least find striking
is that each tissue is also different from each other.
Now, I'm not going to show you all the data for this, but it turns out if you
take different strains of mice, this largely holds.
And so I think it's really each of our tissues, something about those tissues
in ways that we do not understand seems to have a
distinct nutrient environment that is defining of that
tissue. And I think in terms of thinking about cancer, this matters
because if we simply reformulate media conditions to match what's
found in different tissues, it also matters for how well cancers
can grow. Now again, this is all published data, so I'm just going to
summarize the findings from these things.
But effectively, if we take various, these are from pancreatic cancer, either
primary tumors or metastasis, and we try to grow them in blood-like conditions,
well, they grow quite well. They actually grow quite similarly to what we see in
tissue culture. But if we go to the more restricted conditions that we found in
various tissues, they have clear preferences for nutrient environments, in this
case, the nutrient environment found in the pancreas.
And in that same paper, that was work of Charanu Sivananthan.
In the same paper that I alluded to earlier that Keane Abbott published,
he also did a lot of work to try to dissect, well, what's actually
driving this? And effectively the argument is that it's actually
multiple nutrients cooperating within those environments that are actually
driving this preference to grow in different locations.
Now, what I want to focus on here in terms of today's talk, though, is that while
that's all well and good, but can we actually use this to learn something about
metabolic limitations within cancer?
And so one approach that we had to do that is we said, well, if it's true that
nutrients vary in different tissues across the body,
well, a good question to ask is, well, what actually is
responsible for this variance? That is, what's actually different
across each of these different sites?
And so one can use various math things and other ways to
look at this. I don't want to get into the details of that, but one thing
that really stands out that is characteristic of each tissue is that
each tissue is very different in terms of its nucleotide and nucleotide
precursor availability. That is, some
tissues might be high in salvageable purines.
Some tissues might be high in salvageable pyrimidines.
Some might have thymidine, some might have cytosine, et cetera.
And this to us was very striking for a variety of reasons.
But to study this, we needed to come up with a system to actually model it.
And the way we decided to do this was actually to use acute
lymphoblastic leukemia. And we did this for a couple reasons.
One is because with the help of Jana Pickman, who's a pediatric
oncologist at Dana-Farber, she had access to bone marrow
plasma from a large number of kids that happened to have
a B-cell ALL, and they had stored banked bone
marrow plasma as well as blood. And so we did
quantitative mass spec on part of our effort to try to understand different
nutrient environments across tissue.
I will say the one nutrient environment, at least to the extent bone marrow plasma,
is reflective of bone marrow, and that's a debate we could have, but that
looks a lot like plasma. So that's one good thing.
And the other thing is that this is acute lymphoblastic leukemia.
So it grows in the bone marrow, it grows in the blood, so this is a physiological
environment for this. Now, it turns out you do this
in humans, we could also do it in a mouse model of Philadelphia-positive
B-ALL. This is a mouse model we got from Mike Hemann's lab.
He didn't originally make it. It was originally made by Chuck Sherr many, many
years ago. It's basically BCR-ABL
expressed on a, I think it's P19 background.
These mice get B-ALL, and it's a very specific model of
B-ALL. But regardless, if we simply ask what's
different between the blood of either humans or mice that
have lymphoblastic leukemia versus healthy
controls, well, again, it's nucleotides
that really stand out. And so we decided, well, maybe
we could actually leverage this then as a system to try to
understand how it is that this variation in nucleotide levels
might actually matter. Now, the way we did this
is Rayan El-Bashir, a
soon-to-be graduated PhD student from my lab,
worked with Keane initially, although did most of this work on her own, where she
ultimately decided, well, let's formulate media
conditions very similar to what I showed you before and see if we could actually
study what actually might matter between sort of the way we
standardly grow cells or not. Now, we decided to do this in
mouse. You could criticize us for doing it in mouse.
I know that's kind of out of fashion right now, but I will tell you the reason we
did it in mouse, because we wanted to be able to go back into the mouse after we
manipulated these things and look at it.
So there are some interesting mouse-human differences if people want to talk about
that. But regardless, I think we learned something here ultimately
that I think does apply to humans, even if the exact details of what we found
may be mouse specific. But regardless, this is just to point out that we can
take B-ALL cells, and if we grow them in media that's formulated,
what Rayan called MPM for mouse plasma-like media,
it grows almost as well as it does in RPMI.
But if you just do metabolomics and you just ask what's different?
Again, what's different is nucleotides.
Really underscoring that nucleotide metabolism
is affected by these different
environments.So what Rayann wanted to do, somewhat
inspired by Gertha's work, is actually use
tracing. And so from a methods workshop, this is basically using isotope
tracing. The way we did this for the aficionados out there is we basically
used glutamine tracing, which labels bases only, coupled
with glucose tracing. So glucose tracing, if it labels just the five
carbon ribose, you can largely tell what's salvaged because
that has to be salvaged of a preformed base.
Or you can see glucose also contribute
to the bases as well. But
regardless, we could use the various isotopomer distributions and estimate
it from those, how much of the nucleotide pools growing in
RPMI versus mouse plasma-like media conditions were
coming from different sources, and perhaps not surprisingly, because your
RPMI has absolutely no nucleotides in it.
It's all from de novo synthesis. Whereas under salvage conditions,
well, they salvage the nucleotides.
Now, many people say, "Well, of course, we've known that for a long time.
It's expensive to make nucleotides.
If you need nucleotides, well, you'll salvage them if you make them
available." But where this gets interesting here is as follows, and that's, well,
what if you add nucleotides to RPMI?
It makes zero difference on how well the cells grow.
But if you take the nucleotides away from the mouse plasma-like media, well,
now the cells don't grow as well, which means they care about those
nucleotides. And in fact, if you knock out salvage enzymes
versus synthesis enzymes, you actually learn something even more
interesting. So if you look here at this experiment, if we knock out
synthesis enzymes, well, if you grow cells in RPMI, these two gray bars right
here, what you see is, of course, they don't grow without synthesis enzymes, and
they don't care about salvage. This is a salvage knockout.
But you notice here, just like you might have predicted from there, you care about
salvage in the MPM condition, but you also still care
about synthesis. And we found this a little bit weird
because this is not a nutrient-deprived condition.
Yes, it's nutrient different. It's not what's in RPMI.
It's different, but not necessarily
nutrient deprived, which really then raised the question, well, why is it
that nucleotide synthesis is specifically constrained in these plasma-like
conditions but not constrained in RPMI?
And so Rayann considered all the various possibilities, and I'll just go right to
the experiment here that says exactly what's going on.
So this is just metabolomics, and there's three metabolites that
stand out like a sore thumb. So you basically only see them
accumulate under MPM conditions where you take the
nucleotides away. This is GAR, ICAR, and
DUMP. All of these, what they share in common is they're immediately
upstream of a folate-utilizing step, and to the extent we
can measure the downstream thing, so dTMP, it's depleted
under the MPM conditions. So this screamed to us that this
is probably related to folates. It turns out, well, what
are folates? Well, it turns out we grow cells in RPMI in 2.2
micromolar folates. We had measured, this is actually probably
super physiological. We can talk about that in a minute, but we had formulated this
originally with 115 nanomolar folates.
But regardless, if I simply take the folate level in
MPM and make it look like RPMI, now they don't care about
nucleotide salvage at all. So folates are driving this
phenotype. And in fact, this here is the
physiological range of folates, at least the one that's published in mice.
If you titrate, and this is RPMI is way up here.
If you titrate over this range, you can actually determine how fast cells
grow simply by the folates you provide them in the media.
And for those folate aficionados out there, it does matter if you use
folic acid or if you use things like 5-methyl
THF. Happy to talk about that if people are interested.
It shifts the curve slightly, but the finding is almost
identical. Now, why do I point this out?
Is because we tend to think of what's in culture as physiological, but it's
not. This is physiology. Physiology is
folate depletion. It turns out that standard mouse
chow is actually high in folates because we breed the mice.
But regardless, the standard folate in human blood, this is Rayann, who did the
work, her folate concentration is 31 nanomolar.
So we're actually overestimating in some of what we're doing there.
And I will point out that this actually matters because if we actually manipulate
folate levels in the mouse, we can actually control how fast the B-ALL grows,
particularly if we get rid of salvage and also affect survival of the mouse,
which I think this was important to us because I think it really pointed out that
us studying nucleotide metabolism is we're missing
something here important because it's far more constrained than normal.
It may explain, Gertha did a beautiful study where she actually looked and saw
folate salvage across many, many tissues in vivo, and I think this is actually
part of maybe that phenotype.
And then why does this actually matter for progression?
Well, the reason it matters for progression, we think, is as follows, and that is
that if you actually have issues with your nucleotides, it actually
rarely matters for RNA-based things.
It largely matters for DNA things, for DNA synthesis leading to
replication stress. And it turns out what actually happens, why the cells
grow slower in those conditions is because they experience DNA
replication stress. And this DNA replication stress from work from Peggy
Sue and Brian Doe, that again, is published, I don't have time to go into it, is
sufficient to be able to change gene expression state in cells,
which I think is actually interesting because I think what this says is that many
cells in our body, because they actually are in this situation where
they are constrained for synthesis, if they're in environments
where salvage is not perfect, they can now get this situation that might drive
gene expression changes, which of course is interesting in thinking about a
developmental mechanism, but it's also interesting in thinking about this
as sort of how could you get changes in gene expression related to cancer
biology.All right. Now in the remaining time, I want
to switch gears a bit and talk about whole body metabolism.
And this is really a phenotype that we've been interested in a
very long time, which is this notion that in pancreas cancer,
tissue wasting starts actually very, very early.
This is work we did with Brian Wolpin's lab, where basically they used a
variety of methods that even before patients are diagnosed, even with
non-metastatic cancer, they show evidence of muscle wasting.
And I'll point out this actually correlates with new onset diabetes, the muscle
wasting that is seen. And we've been interested in trying to figure this out, and
we've been trying to figure it out largely by using transplant models, which not
everyone in the field loves. But I will tell you, if you grow a tumor in the
pancreas, as the tumor grows, you end up getting
wasting of muscle and fat. Now, Yedij Goltekan, a
current postdoc in the lab, has been trying to sort out what's actually going on
with this phenotype, and I think largely
what he finds is also what Laura Deny, a former postdoc in the
lab, found and published back in 2018, is that what correlates
with this early tissue wasting with pancreatic tumor growth is
actually loss of normal pancreatic exocrine function.
Now, back when we published this paper, we said it was only about fat.
It turns out that's because we were using,
basically pancreatic enzyme replacement that was bought off of Amazon.
So when we use pharmaceutical-grade Amazon replacement, well, now we can fix
the muscle wasting. So I think it's really something about the
pancreas tumor causing exocrine insufficiency that is at
least driving the early tissue wasting in the mouse.
Now, many people discount this data because they say, well, this is not a good
model of pancreas cancer. And part of why they say that is the following, and
that's because I alluded to this earlier.
Humans with pancreas cancer get diabetes and mice don't.
In fact, mice are hypoglycemic at the time when they
lose the muscle and fat. Now, this makes sense.
If you're not digesting your food, you're going to be energy deficient.
You're going to be hypoglycemic. And if we give them exocrine replacement, we can
fix the blood glucose. So that actually sort of supports that.
Well, Yedij actually did an experiment to formally show that this
was the case, and it actually provided a really interesting clue that I think
explains the difference between mouse and humans.
This is a cool isotope tracing experiment that he did where effectively
he gave mouse a bolus of glucose or a bolus
of labeled glucose in starch and then looked at absorption and
disposal. So you'll see if I give labeled starch, the mouse with
pancreas cancer, because it doesn't have exocrine function or reduced exocrine
function, doesn't break down the glucose.
So you see less of a glucose spike and it's cleared.
But if you give a free glucose bolus, well, you actually see the same spike you see
in the control animals, and you also see that the area under the curve
is greater, which is consistent with reduced insulin function, which is
exactly the diabetes that you see in pancreas cancer.
And so we think there is reduced pancreatic
normal endocrine function that's happening in both mouse and humans.
And there's even evidence for this here.
Yes, insulin is low because the mice cannot digest their food.
But glucagon is also low, even though the mice are hypoglycemic, which
is also another sign of endocrine dysfunction.
Now, this is interesting because this is a dietary difference between mice and
humans.
You as humans, I don't care how good you are, unless you're Lou or Josh, who eats
only a ketogenic diet,
you eat free glucose. But the mice eat what we feed them, and there is
almost no free glucose in mouse chow.
We give mice a diet that is largely starch.
That's what it is. If we simply add free glucose to the
mouse chow, well, look at what happens. We now get elevation in blood glucose.
You get it in a wild-type mouse as well.
But it happens in the mice with pancreas cancer.
It does nothing to the muscle wasting, but it actually prevents the fat wasting,
which actually is the pattern that you see in humans.
So we think what the difference between humans and mice is is that humans have
exocrine and endocrine dysfunction.
But because they're eating free glucose, they actually have less fat wasting, more
muscle wasting, because this doesn't do anything to muscle wasting.
And they end up, in some cases, being hyperglycemic.
But not all human patients are hyperglycemic because it's probably dietary
dependent. We can do the exact same experiment
to prove that protein digestion is also affected. I won't take you through it.
It's basically the same result I showed you earlier, except using labeled
protein as protein or as free amino acids.
And if we simply give mice free amino acids, well, now we can fix the muscle
wasting. But it does absolutely nothing to the fat wasting, which actually is
further evidence that it's this normal pancreatic dysfunction that's
ultimately leading, at least in the mouse models, to this early tissue wasting
and actually defines which compartment is actually affected.
Now, I don't have time to get into this because I have 17 seconds left, but
in the end, Yedij wanted to ask, does this actually matter?
It turns out if you block the fat wasting, so we can do that dietarily in other
ways, it actually doesn't really matter for survival, but blocking the muscle
wasting does. And the most effective way to block the muscle wasting, at least in
his hands, was to knock out autophagy in the muscle.
So this is an ATG7 knockout, which is actually pretty good at preventing the
muscle wasting and also extends survival of the
mouse. Now, I'm out of time, so I want to close there.
But I think ultimately what this is saying is that it's actually an
effect of the cancer on the host that's leading to this systemic
effect, at least in this disease early on.
And it's not, I don't think that the cancer is
specifically doing this. I think the cancer doing this, this effect on the host, if
anything, is probably restraining the growth of the cancer.
But we have to be careful if we're actually going to go in and try to fix this.
Because if you fix it dietarily, well, you might protect the muscle, but now you're
also going to give the nutrients that are needed to the cancer.
Whereas, I don't know, if it was a way to block muscle-specific tissue
wasting, that would be a great thing to do.
Although pharmacologically, I'm not quite sure how to do that.
But with that, I just want to close. I want to thank the people in my lab.
I want to thank our collaborators, our funding sources, particularly the
Stephenson Global Pancreatic Cancer Research Institute, who really made
it possible for us to do especially the work I presented later.
And I also want to give a shout-out.
I have five trainees who happen to be here at this meeting.
All of them have posters. Two of them are undergraduates.
So Dia and Cindy, I encourage you guys go to check out their
posters. None of them are going to talk about anything that I presented in my talk,
and they all do awesome work. All right.
Thank you guys so
much.Yeah.
Thank you for the talk. My name is Omid Hajiasani from Case Western Reserve.
My question is about the first set of data that you showed about different tissues.
They have markers of different nutrient available to them.
Usually when these experiments are done, either a chow diet similar to average
Western diet has been
administered. I was wondering if we change a diet going to high
protein, ketogenic,
are we going to see different markers?
Or are we going to see that these tissues pick up the new nutrient and convert them
to what they're used to?
Yeah, that's a really great question.
So we've done a little bit work, and so what I will tell you is that if you change
the diet, you will affect the nutrients available in tissues,
but it's not as simple as what you would say, right?
So if you take glucose out of the-- Normal physiology still works.
Some nutrients are buffered better than others.
On a principle component plot, it'll move, but I
think there still is a defined characteristic of each
tissue that is then modulated by diet.
Now, I think this is a really interesting thing, because if you think about, well,
what are the dietary things that might increase cancer risk or kick off something
happening? Do those small changes matter?
I think that, in my view, remains an open question, although
many many groups, I think, are interested in this as a possibility.
I find the idea attractive, but we'll see.
Thank you.
But you have to measure. The key thing is you have to measure, you can't...
Karen did beautiful work. You take serine and glycine out of the diet, serine goes
down, but not all nutrients will do that.
Congratulations. It's beautiful work.
So, I realize that Josh's work a lot similar to yours.
That regarding the ketone diet, I wonder if
you see the similar, like ketone diet affected folate
change in... And that's question one.
And in Josh's study, he showed that
ketogenic diet also sensitize
the cancer cells to gemcitabine. I wonder if your
folate deficient also kind of
sensitize tumor cells to the chemotherapy.
Yeah. Both good questions. So we've not tested
what ketogenic diet does to folate levels.
My prediction is it shouldn't affect them.
I can't think of how that would be the case, but without measuring it, it's
impossible to know. In terms of does low folate
sensitize you to gemcitabine? We didn't try that because gemcitabine's never used
as a therapy in B-ALL, but it is something
that has been on the list to try in other cancers like pancreas
cancer. But without doing the experiment, I can't really speak
to answer the question. I could sort of do hand-waving reasons why it might
and hand-wavy reasons why it doesn't, which means we should do the experiment.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah. Garreta.
Hi, Matt. Amazing talk. I was very curious about the folate and
the salvagable nucleotides, and I was wondering whether you have
looked,
whether maybe what the nucleotides are doing is maybe fixing the
redox issue. Folates are really at an interesting
intersection that would need more redox, like
NADPH or NADH, and I wonder if you've looked at that
or thought about it.
Yeah. We've certainly thought about it. I'm obsessed with redox like you are.
I think the one experiment that may speak to that is whether or not
5-methylTHF versus folic acid makes a difference.
So for those who don't know, 5-methylTHF has to be recaptured.
They're different oxidation states, so they have to be captured in different ways.
We actually don't see a difference between those two in terms of constraints.
Where you become depleted is slightly different.
It turns out cells take up 5-methylTHF slightly better than folic
acid.
But
apart from that,
no. Although I think ultimately redox state
probably also serves as some constraints, but
I think it's a separate phenotype from the folic acid.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you. It's a very interesting project.
And
I'm a surgeon. I'm focusing on the cervical adenocarcinoma.
Mm-hmm.
And after I knocking down my target gene, I
performed the metabolism pathway, and I also
performed a mass spectrometry.
Mm-hmm.
I want to put them using KGD pathway, and I want
to find my best candidate gene. So I have a
question.
Could you give me some suggestion?
How can I find the best candidate?
Yeah. You and everyone else in this room would like the answer to
that question.
I would say that's a very common...
Actually, I'm sure other speakers and other people in this field
get the same question all the time.
People often say, "Which genes, which pathways?" I think,
in my view, it's sort of you roll up your sleeves, and you look at candidates, and
you start testing them. I haven't found a better way to do that.
I'm at MIT, so I hear about AI all the time.
I have to talk about AI all the time.
And so is there a way to build metabolic models?
Lots of people have built metabolic models.
There's lots of various computational tools out there that try to
align metabolomics data and gene expression data.
In fact, Amit, written up there, he...
Or not Amit, but a different person written up there, Alexander Greer, in
my lab, is actually working on exactly that problem.
But as of right now, I don't think I can point you to one gold standard thing.
But you should ask the other speakers after the session.
Thank you.
Yep.
Okay.
Go over here.
Hi. Sharon Lussier from the NCI.
Mm-hmm.
I had a question about your fat wasting.
All of your data show white adipocytes, white adipose tissue.
Mm-hmm.
I was wondering if you did check the brown adipose tissue since
They have a lot of commonalities with-
Yeah
... cancer cells.
Yeah, it's a great question. It's not something that we have focused on as much,
largely because we don't see a lot of increased energy expenditure in the pancreas
cancer context that we're looking at, at least early pancreas
cancer. There's certainly other models with increased energy expenditure,
and many others in the field have looked at brown adipose tissue.
It's probably something we should do at some point, is the,
for those in the field, the Beijing of the white adipose tissue, are we seeing
some of that?
Some people have published that in a couple pancreas cancer models, but at least
histologically, we've never really seen evidence for that.
Again, looking at early tissue wasting, which at
least in our hands, I think is related to the normal pancreatic
exocrine dysfunction.
But as a later phenomena, there was a great session earlier on
cachexia. Hopefully, some of you got to attend that
session. We were actually chatting a bit after that session, and
largely, I think we have to be careful because we want one unifying
explanation for things.
Yeah.
I think that can happen in some contexts, but not all contexts.
And personally, I think tissue wasting and cachexia may not always be the same
thing, and cachexia is probably multiple different things.
But that's a whole field.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi, Matt. Beautiful work. I was just wondering if you've
looked at other disease or other
tissue contacts and scenarios with folate supplementation such
as pregnancy and also breast cancer and-
Yeah
... any ties.
Yeah. We have not yet. It's relatively new data
I'm showing you. The world, though, has looked at this.
I will actually say that folate levels are actually
correlated in the opposite direction with colon cancer risk.
Now, whether or not that's colon cancer specific or
it's tumor initiation versus what you require
to actually grow is not so clear.
The discovery of antifolates actually came from Farber actually making the
observation. He actually gave the kids folic acid first, and it made them worse.
That's why he gave antifolates. So, I think there's a long history,
most of it old or from the epidemiological literature around
folic acid. And so I want to be clear, I have no
recommendation. You probably, if you're going to have kids, you should
take prenatal vitamins because we know that that will prevent neural tube
defects.
In terms of cancer risk, it's probably more complicated.
But I think it's telling us though that the main point is not necessarily high or
low folates as a cancer treatment.
It's really that nucleotide metabolism is actually much more constrained because of
the folate levels. And I think if we want to consider how it is that some of our
therapies work, like the gemcitabine questioned earlier, that's something we think
we have to pay more attention to.
Yeah.
All right, last question.
Actually, one of my points, the folate actually
accelerates polyp formation and tumor-
Yep.
...
growth .
Yep. I'm glad you brought it up because I was going to.
But my question is, because of the effect of folate of the
growth of the leukemia cells, do you know the
mechanism? Because the pyrimidine pathways have been
implemented in maturation of T cells and so on.
So do you know how?
Yeah, so I think where we see the biggest effect is if we get rid of salvage.
So I think it's probably helping synthesis go faster.
And I would argue it's probably because nucleotide
synthesis seems to be one of the rate-limiting things for cell
proliferation. That would be my argument, but proving
that is more complicated than-
So there was no change in differentiation or something like that?
Yeah.
We didn't actually look at that.
There's interesting reasons why there might be, but we didn't look.
Okay.
All right. Since you're standing there, is it a quick question?
It is a quick question.
Okay. Yeah, sure.
I was just wondering, in your
muscle wasting knockout mice, was it like the autophagy
knockout mice? Does it impact the tumor
progression itself? I was just wondering whether-
Yeah
... the muscle wasting is helping in tumor progression.
Yeah. It definitely slows the tumor growth as well.
Absolutely. And just by the way, it was the ATG7 knockout in the muscle,
either done in a GEM model or transplanted into an ATG7,
Eileen White's ATG7 knockout mouse for the...
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you, guys. Thank you for sticking to the bitter end.
Thank you to all the speakers. Enjoy the rest of the meeting.